Another year over.
Where do they go to?
It's a mystery.
Now, it's December. So much to remember before Christmas Eve.
I'm already late and my train is delayed.
Disruption on the line.
I race into work and the place is berserk.
Yes, it's Christmas time.
I want to find the greatest gift I can give my family...
...but right now, I don't have time to breathe.
I want to find the greatest gift I can give my family.
The greatest gift I can give is me!
Now, I can meet with the boss and empty out my inbox, all simultaneously,...
...leaving me time to spend with my family and friends where I want to be.
I want to find the greatest gift I can give my family.
The greatest gift that I can give is me!